you went to oxford you studied russian
literature and you speak fluent russian
did you ever have your iq tested i mean
did anybody give you
what is your iq do you know the number i
do i have to ask my mom it was it was it
was very high and i and i think she had
me tested because you know very bright
children it's nearly unbearable i'm sure
that's why she
were you in the genius category
i think it was quite high yeah wow i'll
text her and ask her she'll be awake
we're gonna get
anywhere between 140 and 165 i mean you
might you might really be that you might
be mensa you know what i'm talking about
no i think i was yeah i think but you
know they tested when i was at you know
young so i mean i'm sure i've burnt a
few brain cells now
when you date dudes it can't be so
casual right because i mean you must see
everyone as like a [ __ ] you know or an
idiot do you ever just sit there and go
oh this [ __ ] guy i mean he's handsome
and everything but he's a [ __ ] idiot
don't you think most women say that
yeah
i'm a dude i've heard so many women say
why why why am in such idiots like i
think that's a thing i don't know if
that's personal to me
i've always found i can forgive an awful
lot if somebody's funny so
you know i think there's a certain
degree of intelligence in somebody being
funny that i'm you know able to mess
with so no more from your mother what
your iq is no um let me just call her
phone and see okay good
that's a good that's a legit question
just actually on the show currently he
just wants to know what my iq was when
you had it tested when i was little
um
your iq is 152. do you realize that's
like almost einstein level like i said
i'm sure i've become progressively more
stupid
oh i wish i had a 152 iq that's mine you
don't every single doctor every single
person i've ever come across has said
you'd be so much happier if you were 30
that's smart i'm sure that's true listen
trust me i'm 30 less smart
152 the [ __ ] you must think up it's no
good to me though this is i mean it's
really not helpful in in my career i
just think it's
i've been a handicap actually you know
what my iq is it's 76 okay
let me see
that's absolutely like what is yours
oh it's 179. i didn't want to say that
actually
robin don't blow this for me 179. it's
i've been tested they they they can't
even find the test it's so there's not
even a you've gone off the charts they
said i'm like lex luthor from the
superman comics like i'm basically
you're a medical emergency yes they're
like wow
i went for the iq because my brain was
dripping out of my ears